so say what let me know when you're
recording hello audience members this is
Nick Offerman and I'm about to be
spilling some tea in your direction
figuratively the character of Ron
Swanson was created by Mike Schur and
Greg Daniels they met us a Burbank city
official who was anti-government and a
libertarian and they thought that was
really funny
they didn't know I was gonna play Ron
Swanson when they thought of the
character but then almost immediately
they said oh we like Nick so he's gonna
have a mustache he talks very slowly
we should probably justify his love of
red meat in some way because Nick is
spilling out over his pleated JCPenney
trousers the scripts on personal
recreation were so good that we never
needed to improvise but we had such a
cast of amazing creative heads that they
would then encourage us once we had
achieved the script if we had any good
ideas you know go ahead and throw them
in when I ordered that platter that
serves 12 people and I say I know what
I'm about son I believe I came up with
that line but it was just they already
had a line there you know it was it's
all very collaborative most of the
credit has to go to the writers
[Music]
it was the episode where everybody got
to pick their bachelor party and the
character of Jerry Jim o'heir took us to
his ice cream shop and we were all
indulgently chowing down on ice cream
and Chris Pratt had a huge cone of
strawberry ice cream and he sculpted a
vagina into it and just kept
surreptitiously shall he tickle me and
you know you try not laughing when Chris
Pratt shows you his tiny strawberry ice
cream vagina she's my teacher she's my
hero I saw her on Will & Grace 18 years
ago when we met it was like seeing Mel
Brooks or Carol Burnett or just some
legend I thought oh you were born an
encyclopedia of great comedy and she's
11 years older than me so there's always
been a great teacher-student
relationship
Parks and Rec was the first time when
she played Tammy - the first time that
we got to work together as a team we'd
often work together but never where it
was the two of us it was incredibly
difficult because of all the people in
the world she knows how to push my
buttons and so to then put that in a
scene where she's being funny and I'm
not supposed to laugh at her was an
incredibly difficult task and sometimes
I succeeded we all keep in touch we have
an ongoing cast thread that we text on
almost daily some buddies are always got
something going on a couple times a year
we're trying to get together to have
dinner
Retta has a new show on NBC red also has
a book coming out so the threads been a
little red a heavy but but that's great
Amy just finished directing a movie
called wine country so everybody's all
always got stuff happening and it's a
wonderful
family feeling keeping us all in touch
the best thing I took from the set was
all of the trim and doors and windows
from the set of the the main Parks and
Rec office somehow found their way to my
woodshop and we milled them up into
strips of red oak and then glued them up
into blanks and made them into canoe
paddles which we then gifted to the cast
and producers and hanging in my shop is
that that original huge framed picture
of a brunette woman holding out a plate
of bacon and eggs that it's what I'm
referring to when I say I I'm a simple
man
I like ladies with dark hair and
breakfast food so that hangs in my shop
and inspires me every day
[Music]